la haute vallée de chevreuse en
opération séduction à paris depuis ce
jeudi 12 octobre un stand de s'y mettre
car est installé au sein de bercy
village dans le cadre de la première
édition de destination parc
un événement qui regroupe les 51 parcs
naturels régionaux de france
les parcs naturels régionaux ne sont pas
forcément très connu du grand public et
surtout des parisiens et puis parce que
les gens ne connaissent pas forcément
leur territoire et on s'est dit que
d'avoir un événement un peu grand public
pour sensibiliser les gens à
l'environnement à la découverte des
saveurs et des territoires c'est une
bonne occasion de le faire sur paris les
20 représentants du pnr de chevreuse
proposer des questionnaires sur leur
territoire mais également des
dégustations d'une douzaine de produits
régionaux
les visiteurs ont pu goûter du sirop de
chevreuse du fromage de la ferme de
coubertin du miel ou encore du jus de
poire de gambe et on est en relation
directe avec eux sachant qu'on travaille
à peu près toute l'année avec eux et sur
certains événements on essaye de
valoriser leurs produits de proposer aux
gens du jus de pommes etc afin qu'ils se
fassent connaître
donc ça s'est fait un petit peu
naturellement en fait par rapport au
bien qu'on a tout le temps avec eux pour
cette première journée des milliers de
visiteurs n'ont pas hésité à aller sous
la tente pour découvrir la haute vallée
de chevreuse je n'y suis jamais allé je
suis passé en voiture près mais sans
m'arrêter
c'est très bien moi je trouve que c'est
formidable ça nous permet de découvrir
des régions qu'on connaît pas
éventuellement si vous aussi vous voulez
découvrir de nouveaux parcs régionaux
l'événement est organisé jusqu'à ce
dimanche dans le 12e arrondissement de
paris plus de soixante mille personnes
sont attendues sur le site pendant ces
quatre jours de présentation